Now you needn't prefix
yourself to just sums.
Consider this example, imagine this as
a gorgeous terrain of hills and valleys,
and I'm sorry, Georgia Tech and Udacity
only pay me to do eight bit landscapes.
Now suppose at each point in the terrain
you actually know the elevation.
Here are labeled as integers.
Now, suppose you have a friend,
who stands here and
looks straight ahead, what will he or
she be able to see without occlusion?
I claim one way to figure it out
is to do a prefix-max computation.
The input array to a prefix max
would be the list of elevations.
A prefix max computation would ask for
each point in the terrain, what is
the largest elevation I've seen so far?
Your friend could see as long as the
elevations in the terrain were no higher
than his or her position.
Let's compute the cumulative
max at each point.
Now to figure out whether your friend
could see this awesome landmark in
the distance, just look at the maximum
elevation at that point and
compare it to your friend's height.
In this case is 4 is
a lot bigger than 1.5, so
your friend has no hope of seeing
my beautiful Eiffel Tower.
Now the generalization of a prefix sum
is sometimes called a scan operation.
To use a scan in an algorithm,
all you have to do is say that you're
doing it and say what the operator is.
For example if we were doing
a prefix sum then we would say we
were doing an add-scan, that's
a scan and the operator is a plus.
Or as in the previous example we did a
max scan, you could have product-scans,
logical add scans, or-scans,
whatever your heart desires.